smartphone users the world over have a
new obsession the playing pokemon go
when and wherever they can the amp for
this virtual pocket monster hunt has
already been downloaded a hundred
million times the game looks like a GPS
map but pokemons are lurking they can be
in just about any public space when
players get close the smart phones
vibrate they then have to capture the
pokemon with the help of a virtual ball
16 year old Meg whale schultz from
western germany is a fan was first
injured over on the game brings so many
different age groups together when i
walk through the park I see lots of
older and younger people MIG well
Schultz isn't satisfied just to play the
game he's developing an app that reveals
the pokemons current locations and the
players don't even have to be close by
wisconsin i got the idea because i
didn't feel like just randomly hunting
for pokemons professional pokemon
coaches are catching on in the u.s. they
take other people's smartphones outside
for some twenty dollars an hour that
kilometers they clock up help to get
their clients to the next level so we
put the ad up and then I couldn't even
do it by myself I had two phones I was
doing like 10 hour days and i got my
friend Jordan to come along with me and
now it looks like we're gonna have to
hire another person so it's been booming
also profiting from the hype our shops
and restaurants hosting so-called poker
stops one barn undhan has already
adapted to the new clientele creating
various Pokemon cocktails some of them
non-alcoholic in Indonesia some pocket
monsters are hiding in museums and
luring in crowds of vistas for young
people a new reason to visit historical
sites
you